after many years of rumors and waiting
metroid 5 aka metroid dread is finally
releasing on the nintendo switch metroid
is a series that's been around since the
famicom and nes days but never quite
reached the same mainstream recognition
as mario or zelda but there's been
somewhat of a metroid resurgence lately
samus returns on 3ds prime 4 in
development and now metroid dread which
wraps up the main story started all the
way back in the original game even the
announcement trailer for metroid dread
has over 2 million views on nintendo's
youtube channel as of making this video
but if you're looking to finally give
metroid a shot you might be asking
yourself well does the original 8-bit
game hold up is it worth going all the
way back to the start before dread to
see how it all began well in this video
i'm going to answer that question as i
revisit the original metroid the
challenge is metroid the power is
nintendo defend the planet zebus against
the evil mother brain it's survival or
destruction to battle or die metroid
only from nintendo for those who don't
know the original metroid has a very
simple premise defeat the metroid and
destroy the mother brain but if you flip
through the pages of the original
instruction booklet you get a little
more backstory to boil it down as best i
can galactic federation exists and
there's peace and prosperity between the
planets but space pirates exist and they
don't want peace so the galactic
federation police has formed to stop
them but the space pirates were too cool
and too awesome to be caught so space
hunters or bounty hunters were sent to
capture them in the year 20x5 the space
pirates steal a capsule from a research
lab containing an unknown deadly life
form that was dubbed metroid the space
pirates who hate peace and happiness
want to use the metroid as a weapon to
destroy the galaxy how original the
federation police then locate the space
pirates headquarters on a planet known
as zebus or well zebeth according to the
original game's translation the
federation police are unable to get into
the planet as a last resort the
federation police call in the best space
hunter in the galaxy samus aaron the
game's protagonist to penetrate the
center of the planet and destroy the
leader of the space pirates mother brain
so uh
guess the story isn't so simple after
all
if you're curious about the entire
metroid timeline in the lead-up to
metroid dread well then you're in luck
because we have the complete metroid
timeline explained from our very own
adam mason which i will link in the
description metroid was created after
nintendo's other big hits like donkey
kong super mario bros and the legend of
zelda in an effort to distinguish
metroid from other titles it was decided
that the game would be a non-linear
platforming adventure game with a design
that both encouraged exploration and
collecting new permanent upgrades to
expand your arsenal the title metroid
comes from the combination of the words
metro and android metro because the
planet's design takes inspiration from
the japanese metro subway lines and
android because according to the
instruction manual mentioned earlier
samus is a cyborg their entire body has
been surgically strengthened with
robotics giving them superpowers
notice how i changed the pronouns in
that quote well it's no secret nowadays
but back in the day if you finished
metroid fast enough it would be revealed
to the player that underneath the suit
samus was actually a woman whether the
original instruction booklet called sam
as a hee because the person writing it
didn't know or they didn't want to spoil
the surprise we'll never really know as
the story goes this happened because the
production of metroid was a very free
working environment someone just said
hey wouldn't it be kind of cool if it
turned out the person inside the suit
was a woman sure the original 1979 alien
film was a big influence on metroid and
the protagonist of that film is also a
woman but the protagonist of metroid a
brand new video game from the biggest
video game company of the time being one
of the first female protagonists in
video games was a big deal especially in
1986 and samus is considered to be a
breakthrough for female characters in
video games to this day so not only did
metroid go on to inspire the
metroidvania genre as seen in video
games like hollow knight and axiom verge
it was also among the first games to
feature a female protagonist so despite
how anyone feels about actually playing
this game it's definitely an important
one in the history of video games and
all that's to say
i didn't really like playing the
original metroid or rather i don't feel
like the game is aged very well it's not
just because the game is old there are
plenty of nes games that i think are
still fun like the original super mario
bros but with metroid what was once
innovative now feels like a relic of the
past at the end of the day it's not
right default in nes game for what it
isn't so i'm not going to do that rather
here's why i don't recommend forcing
yourself through the original metroid in
2021 for starters this game is tough
feel free to tell me in the comments
that i'm not a real gamer but with samus
only being able to aim up left or right
it can be hard to hit anything that
isn't exactly lined up with you and you
can only move so fast meaning dodging
isn't always the best solution either if
you die you go all the way back to the
beginning or at least all the way back
to the beginning of a new zone since the
game has multiple some people might
enjoy the challenge but i really don't
like being forced to traverse back to
the same place over and over every time
i die and start back from square one you
also start the game with only 30 health
and 30 might seem like a big number but
it's really not a lot when the max is 99
it can be upgraded by finding energy
tanks and you keep those energy tanks
even when you die when you do die it
still goes back down to 30 and those
extra energy tanks are just empty want
more health better get used to farming
enemies for five extra health at a time
given the fact that drops are random
this could take a while or you could
just try to power your way through with
dirty health it's kind of a lose-lose
scenario the game also has no map and a
lot of areas look exactly the same so
it's really easy to get lost it's one
thing to get booted back to the
beginning it's another to have no clear
indication of how to even get back to
where you were plus upgrades and secrets
are so easy to miss and rarely is there
ever any indication that there's a
secret to be found bomb this floor how
would you know to do that this red door
only opens when you shoot it with five
missiles again how would you know to do
that trial and error i don't consider
shooting and bombing every single corner
trial and error just a waste of time but
maybe that's just me oh and those
missiles i mentioned there's a finite
amount want more time to farm enemies
for random drops just like health and
that could take a really long time so if
anything i'm less incentivized to blow
up everything around me when my missiles
are precious resources my capture card
didn't even like this game it kept
smearing for some reason in my opinion
one of the only redeeming qualities of
this game is the music it's so iconic
and never gets tiring even if i was
stuck for a while or kept dying and
trying to get back to where i was and
trust me there was a lot of that
[Music]
at this point you might be thinking
yourself well now why is evan so
negative it's a video game from 35 years
ago what did he expect well first of all
you're not entirely wrong but there's a
very specific reason i lean a little
more on the negative side with metroid
and it consists of two additional words
wanna guess what they are
[Music]
in 2004 nintendo released a full remake
of the original metroid titled zero
mission for the game boy advance metroid
zero mission is a full retelling of the
original story with new cutscenes and an
entirely new ending section starring
zero suit samus so if you're looking to
start with the first entry before
metroid dread this is actually the
perfect place to start but it's not just
an improved story oh no this game has
all the bells and whistles save points
so you don't have to go all the way back
to the beginning when you die check a
map
check a system that gives you a
direction to work towards check
difficulty options check being able to
aim your arm cannon in more than three
stiff directions check and here's the
best part once you beat the game you
unlock the original nes metroid yeah
it's included in zero mission two games
in one so if you want to start from zero
mission and play that you also get to
try the original nes metroid for free
the original metroid was a perfect
candidate for a remake and i'm glad
nintendo acted upon that 17 years ago so
okay does the original metroid hold up
in 2021
no
absolutely not play zero mission instead
unfortunately despite just singing the
praises of metroid zero mission there's
only two legal ways to play the game
nowadays you can either track down an
original gba cartridge or you can
download it from the wii u virtual
console i always knew owning a wii u
would be cool one day currently on the
nintendo switch you can only play the
original nes metroid through their
online service but it's very strange to
me that they went out of their way to
make a really solid remake all those
years ago but now only offer the
original inferior version but i will
give credit where credit is due there
are two special versions of metroid on
the switches nes online that start you
later in the game and with a bunch of
upgrades already unlocked so if you
wanted to just dip your toes into the
original metroid this isn't a bad way to
do it since there's a zero mission
shaped hole in the switches library so
in conclusion i really wouldn't call the
original metroid a bad game far from it
actually sure it's not worth playing
nowadays especially with how much better
each subsequent entry in the series is
but the impact the original metroid made
was tremendous and will forever be an
important milestone in video games if
you're looking forward to metroid dread
then consider subscribing to our channel
as we'll have a video review and plenty
of other stuff surrounding the game's
release we've even got a few metroid
videos up now like the metroid timeline
mentioned earlier and a metroid buyer's
guide by john luke if you're wondering
which metroid games to play outside of
the two i spoke about in this video and
if you liked this video i did another
one in the same format titled revisiting
the original no more heroes back in
august which i'll link in the
description below and if there are any
other series you'd like to see covered
in the revisiting the original style
definitely let me know in the comments
as well and hey if you made it this far
and you're listening to me right now
thank you so much for watching i really
do appreciate it for all things gaming
keep it here on gamespot
[Music]
you